the question we try to answer right now
is what other domain of range while each
of these relations okay by the way I
should point out the vast majority of
these things are also functions but
they're not asking you which ones they
are around just like the general word
relations that could be now domain and
range in fact your definition from hey
what is domain what does it mean okay be
careful because he is like definitions
has to be specific because if you just
come a little bit off there tends to be
so concise and succinct but if you a
little bit off you get something to be
different right so I would start with
your phrase all X values I'm not going
to finish there it's all excited with
what I'm going to I see what you're pick
you up I want to avoid the word limit
because limit will mean something very
specific later on even though it sort of
as a comment it's word doesn't it
I understand with all X values for which
the relation is defined or for where the
graph exists does that make sense and
again all they say is where the function
is defined all X values where the
functions on the graph kit includes so
the one that I first got also is
important part babes okay yeah it looks
really started okay we haven't dealt
with it
probably I'm going to do with this bit
later this topic it's what we call a
piecemeal function right so see this guy
here this is a parabola it's just one
piece I could guess actually I don't
have to guess this is gonna be y equals
let's see X exercises to vertex
yeah except you guys okay so this is x
squared minus 2x you used to see things
like this this is the name of the
function this is the actual expression
of the function but this is weird
there isn't one single equation that can
describe both parts of this okay I'll
show you a little bit later on how you
write something like this so that in
some areas your one thing and in other
areas or something else but let's just a
deal with the question of domain abridge
okay domain first which X values which X
values to that graph go through let's
start with the easy part first feelings
are filled and hollow circles this is
borrowing language visual language from
the inequalities and stuff that you draw
another line remember what is it filled
circle mean it means you count that
points like in this case the point is
one right so just with you this right
hand part you go 4-1 you include one and
then you go all the way and there's
nothing to indicate like an asymptote or
something like that
to say oh stop you can't go past here so
that error is telling me go all the way
so I guess I would write that part as X
is greater than or equal to 1 and you
okay with that now when you move over to
the left hand side you've got a hollow
so what does that mean it means 30 quit
that point okay but then says okay now
go all the way to left and we get
there's no indication than it ever stops
right so how would you describe the
domain of this part
and we don't include that okay but you
can see if you put this and this
together right because they're all part
of one rap right
it's a okay I have all of these values
over here and then one I stop but they'd
better k because here this guy picks up
this guy takes over as it were okay
I can change this question very gently
to make it not the case if I for example
put a hollow circle there right what
would that be yeah I wouldn't include
this boundary would I right so in that
case always having this discontinuity
it's break when x equals 1 what does
this relation equals root adds up
nothing
there's no defined point for it but the
glad they've actually given us it's
still okay so therefore the dough base
it is the total domain is all real
values of x that define the all going
over now you can help me enter the range
question area again probably big where
does the graph exist up and down
republic this is a bit easier to think
about it just goes through y equals
negative 1 does it equal to like the
second one no so I'm about to write a
non inclusive and exclusive equality
right Y is going to be above that point
and that's it that's all you have to say
that is the range does it make this now
just really quickly this is not been
closed by the question but it's sort of
a natural question is from why do they
do this why do they make this awkward
like Polar Circle filled circles and the
answer is if it was too dark circles
this is our relation will it always was
a relation right but it can't be a
function why
because now if you take you can be
amended to it if you take the vertical
light now you take your vertical line
there is exactly one point where you
intersect twice right so therefore
you've got one input one x value which
has two outwards that's their good right
so what they want what the what going to
be intending to do is to make sure to
restrict it such that it needs a
function now I put the vertical line
through at every point where it
intersects up reports senator now while
I have your attention while it's on the
board do you want to ask about any of
the other ones
pick a letter anywhere okay which okay
yeah of course these we define so this
guy does the other very strange for
starters let's just look at that
question I was bitching before is this a
function or a relation it's a relation
it clearly fails the vertical line is
pretty badly in fact so I can provide
here or here and up intersect twice what
if were multiple outputs that's their
group okay that like if you draw like PR
you get one two three that's that kind
of a thing but then we think about
domain domain
are there any X values you can find
where the function doesn't exist where
the graph don't go there just no in fact
you don't always even they're always
there in the middle you can get multiple
times so therefore just like before the
domain will be X is all real values will
you be outrage is a little trickier now
I'm going to do just like I did before
I'm going to think about each of the
brunches the pieces stick 1/7 I'm
telling at the top part is a whole
circle the value there is 1 and then it
just goes off and it never stops
okay so how would you express this rate
creative in 1 and above then we look at
this guy there's a circle here so there
you go there with no sign of stopping so
that would be y is less than or equal to
negative on it so this or this that's it
so I guess when you look it from your
work that don't be intimidated by the
weirdness of it just think about it one
piece at a time and you'll be able to
work out the very rich but
[Music]